I had a dream last night that it was the best episode we've ever done.
So I couldn't sleep the rest of the night, got in here, fired up the old machine,
and I'm now waiting on these guys, and I am loose.
I got a little bit of a sweat going.
The hammies are pliable, flexible, and the jaw muscles are ready to really ask some tough questions
and giggle at my funny little friend, Sean and Will.
guys welcome to smartless
smart
hi guys
shut up Sean
I've never I haven't laughed
laughed so hard as I did
today when we were standing on the street
we just come out of a
meeting the three of us
like adults
like adults and Sean
starts to say something
and he like he's doing right now
he he undoes a
top of a bottle of water and he's about to take his hip
or he's going to do it
and Jason slaps it out of his hand.
And lands on the ground.
And it lands on the ground.
Just a fun, a fun little hair pole.
Yeah, just a little fun, fun, fun.
Yeah, just a plastic bottle, nothing broke.
So I reached down to grab it
because it falls at my feet,
and I hand it to Sean, and as he reaches for it,
I just drop it right before he can grab it.
So now that's twice.
That's twice.
It's denied water.
And as it lands on the ground,
Sean reaches down together,
and Jason kicks it.
And it goes flying, hits a curb,
and goes under a parked like construction truck it explodes the top comes flying off the water's everywhere
fucking funny and i haven't laughed that hard i fell to my knees because it was show it was high school all over
again it was like uh it was a little bullying you know it made me laugh and stupid god i love
um jay did you like my cheesecake last night yeah cheese now i i would have i would have liked it a little
firmer, Sean.
Yeah, it was a little too fluff.
You know, it wasn't as gooey
as the last one, so I feel like we're making
progress. I like that. The last one, no, I say this
as a person who I can't even boil water. So
the fact you cook anything is incredible.
It's very impressive. But also,
I didn't know, well, either
that I didn't, I've never made whipped cream
in my life. I didn't know that you just
pour half and half or whatever
in a bowl. And whip it. And you just start
the special whipped cream. You just start whipping it.
I was, my mind was there.
the title.
I was like, oh, you just...
Do you think it's a good idea that you've now learned how easy it is to make whipped cream?
I think so.
I think you know I'm doing it night.
Yeah, you missed out on a good cheesecake last night.
I know.
But then I found out, then Sean told me that the secret ingredient that he does drive an hour
and a half for was a British chocolate, uh, Cadbury white chocolate bar.
No, not Cadbury.
It was another brand, but yeah.
Another brand that we're not going to mention, I guess.
We can't if you want.
It's called Milky Bar.
Well, we already mentioned Cadbury.
so I mean we're kind of committed.
But there's a, is that a thing?
Is that normal that there's a white chocolate candy bar
in most cheesecakes?
Well, no, no.
I just melted it to make kind of like the creamy part.
It was one of many ingredients.
Sorry, listening.
If you thought you tuned into SmartList, it's cookless this week.
Bakeless.
Yeah.
And I was so obsessed with getting any ingredients right.
I drove an hour and a half to get it
because they don't sell them in the United States.
And what did he do, Will, when he got there?
So you drove to another country?
When he drove an hour and a half away to get this to...
What did he do while he was there?
He's like, huh, well, look, here's a rare hamburger joint
that we don't have near us.
Portillo.
Oh, that's why he went to Portillo's.
Yeah, and he put a big burger in his face and a shake, too, I'll bet.
Yeah, I got a shake, a piece of cake, and I got fries and a hot dog.
Wait, you got a shake?
For lunch?
Piece of cake, fries, and a hot dog.
and then two beef sandwiches.
And what's that?
Two beef sandwiches, one for Scotty.
And this is when you were on the mission
to pick up up a school bus?
White chocolate.
Yeah, well, I had, I picked up the white chocolate.
Were you buying for all the kids in the school bus?
No.
I never get it.
So I bought like a little extra stuff
and I put it on the fridge and I'll heat it up later.
Good for you.
Thank you.
Guys, let's get started.
Oh, wow, I thought we had.
This is really exciting, guys, today.
You're going to freak out.
out. Oh, it's your guest. It's my guest
today. I'm so excited, we got my favorite
red-headed firecracker
here today. She's a self-proclaimed
computer nerd, and before becoming one of
my all-time favorite full-fledged movie stars,
she made people websites
for free. In fact, at 14 years old,
she performed a PowerPoint presentation titled Project Hollywood
in order to convince her parents to let her drop out of high school
and move to L.A. from Arizona to pursue
her dreams of becoming an actress. Thankfully, that dream
came true so we could talk to her today.
Her name is Emma Stone.
Emma Stowe.
Emma's a little under the weather.
I'm a little under the weather.
I can't believe you showed up for us.
Did you get into a big pile of bad coke last night, Emma?
Listen, you know what?
You've been there, right?
There's meetings for you.
Yeah, listen, we're saving a seat for you.
I know, thank you.
Are you at home or in a hotel?
I'm in a hotel.
I should be live from our first ever sport.
Thanks for having me.
What an opening.
Emma's been up for four days, listener.
Emma, I don't think of you as a ginger, I guess, per se, when I think of ginger.
But you are.
I'm blonde right now.
No, no, no, I'm not.
I'm actually, I'm blonde.
I have blonde hair right now, and I'm, and I'm, I was born blonde.
Well, I was born hairless, but then I grew blonde hair.
Okay.
Hairless is my podcasting.
Sure.
Give us the full run.
Bravo.
The, yeah, then I died in red.
Yeah, you were.
You were read for a while there, yes?
For a long time.
So much so that people thought it was that you were Natch Red Natch.
But I'm not read Natch.
But wasn't it true?
My mother's red Natch.
Yeah?
You had to be careful with that word Natch.
I have a son who's a Natch Jinge.
Oh.
Yeah.
We love a Natch Jinge.
Oh, my gosh.
Do we ever love a Natch Jinge?
This has gotten so filthy from the very beginning.
I know.
It's fantastic.
That's fantastic.
That's nice.
That's funny.
Hey man.
Do you need a second?
Take a nap.
I've been up for days.
I'm so excited you're on the show with us, Emma.
Thanks for having.
But wait, didn't you die it originally, like when you moved here and you felt like you weren't getting parts or something?
I feel like I read something.
And then you thought maybe your talent, which you're, you know, seeping talent, that that wasn't good enough.
And that's what I was telling everyone.
Yes.
And that's what I kept saying.
Right.
And they went, no, no, no.
That hair has got to go.
But you thought you had to dye your hair?
Is that true?
Yeah, I was, because I moved to L.A. when I was 15,
and so all of the things that I was auditioning for at that time were kind of, you know,
like roles for 15-year-old girls at that time were a lot of girls that were, I guess,
what I was up for was a lot of very blonde cheerleadery kind of roles,
and I didn't fit those very well.
And so I thought if I died my hair brown, it would really set me.
Yeah. How'd that go?
You know, it went great, Jason.
It went really great.
I didn't get any parts after that either.
But a couple of years later, I auditioned for Superbad.
And I was at the camera test for that.
And Judd Apatow said, well, maybe she could have red hair
because the other girl in the movie,
who's my best friend now, Martha McIsaac, had brown hair.
And so we dyed my hair red.
and the rest was, you know.
But is Sean's incredible research accurate?
Were you really doing websites for people?
Like, are you a computer person?
I was in that kind of, you know, 90s computer format.
I don't know if you guys know, you know, Angel Fire, GeoCities, that kind of world where you did.
Very primitive HTML.
This is not coding by any means.
I would not, if you, in fact, I don't have a computer now.
They lent me this computer to be able to do this with you guys.
Oh, do you not do you.
I'm like a Neo-Ludite now.
But back then, I was very into the Internet
and learning about, you know, building drop-down menus and things like that.
I mean, primitive, like, 1998.
What are you looking for?
When you're out there, you're looking,
what are you looking for in a drop-down menu?
Now, see, that's the thing.
See, that's the thing.
When you want somebody to step...
And this keeps me up at night.
If you want somebody, if somebody's looking to step into a really elite drop-
If you're looking for great drop-down in the market.
No, okay.
It needs to be clear, clear, fonts.
We're not using any comic sans on my drop-down items.
No, no, no, no.
We're hitting Helvetica hard.
You now are completely, you don't have a computer at all?
I don't have a computer at all anymore.
Come on.
I really don't.
What about an iPhone?
I have an iPhone, but it's a very cracked.
The incredible new iPhone 15.
I don't.
Sean?
Is this an ad for the thing?
If you want to get rid of your old one.
It is now. We're done with that. Cycles over.
Thank God.
We enjoyed our experience, but oh, mama, was there a heavy rotation?
Sorry about that, America.
Wait, so you do, but do you do email off your phone then?
I do email on my phone and I, you know, just type it with my thumbs.
So no social media, no nothing else.
No.
I love that.
Come on.
No.
That's refreshing.
Thanks so much.
You know, I was thinking yesterday, I said to a friend of ours,
I says to him, I says, friend.
I says friend, I says.
I said, we should, imagine the reset
this planet would get
if we had no social media for six months.
Globally.
Yeah, it'd be pretty wild.
The fucking reset would be incredible.
What do you think would happen?
Well, people would learn how to manage boredom,
which I think is a lost talent.
I know I'd try to teach my kids like,
it's okay if you're bored.
That's actually another word for relaxation.
Like enjoy it take a breath
Being bored is okay like not having anything to do at a red light or an elevator is a good time to kind of like
Reintroduce yourself to yourself for a minute
You know? Well yeah do you ever do that thing? I mean like when you look at people
I've been doing a lot lately well I don't know where I look around and I go
Everybody's on their phone every moment if there's a if there's a down moment and sometimes it's reflexive because people are nervous or you know
It's addictive. Yeah, but when you you wake
up in the morning, you don't have like a loop
that you like to do on a computer.
This is good. Hang on.
What's your computer loop?
Well, you know, you hit the New York Times
and your email and your calendar
and you kind of get your shit together.
I just do all that on my phone.
Okay.
So I'm probably actually on my phone
more than people that have a computer.
But see, what I'm picturing here
is that you've got no reason or excuse
to get up out of the pillows.
Correct.
You're still in the feathers.
You reach over, you grab your phone.
I'm just in a pile of feathers.
You sleep in a pile of feathers for real.
What an angel.
I'm down with that.
You had a nice desktop.
You could get out and into the living room and join the world.
Get yourself a desktop.
This is a great opportunity for a new segment I'm calling.
J.B., walk us through it.
You don't want to follow my morning.
All right, so Emma, which one of your rad projects
are we going to talk about today?
There's so many, okay, so you answer that first.
I don't know.
Which one would you like to talk about?
I want to talk about our childhood.
I want to talk about your birthday last week.
Happy birthday.
What?
Thank you so much.
Yes.
Thank you.
Are we allowed to guess the age?
Can we guess the age?
Oh, this might be mean, but sure.
Go ahead.
No, no, no, no.
How about, I'm going to go with 24.
25.
Will?
I'm going to get real.
Yeah, be real.
I'm not going to play some.
Will and I worked together when I was, I think,
Yes, that's true.
Really?
That was a long time ago.
That is true.
He's going to win then.
So wait, then wait.
Then, Sean, you go next.
Okay.
I was going to say late 20s.
That's very cute, Sean, and sweet.
True, I really don't know.
Are you truly north of 30?
I'm north of 30.
Oh, she is 37.
Come on.
35.
You're the closest by far.
Wow, really?
35.
You don't look 37.
I was just guessing based on what the information.
Okay, well.
Sure, well.
Okay.
No, no.
That's true.
We did.
We did work here.
That was a long time ago.
I know.
What was the job?
Do you remember?
It was called.
The rocker.
You didn't.
Wait, the rocker I still need to see.
And what was the other one I said I needed to see the other day?
Hot Rod.
All right.
Well, let's not go through mine.
Emma, go tell everybody who is in the rock.
Nobody's seen it.
Who is in the rocker?
I know.
The cast is pretty hilarious.
It was Rayne Wilson.
Yeah.
Jason Sedakis.
Yep.
You.
Bradley Cooper.
Yep.
Fred Armisen.
You?
Who directed this?
A guy named Peter Catanio who directed the full Monty.
Peter Catanio.
Yeah, yeah.
And...
John Glazer.
Oh, yeah.
The great John Glazer.
Who did Hot Rod?
Who directed Hot Rod?
That wasn't Yormo, was it?
No, Akiva.
Gotcha.
But the cast was pretty...
It was pretty wild.
Yeah, we were in Toronto.
We were in Toronto.
And I feel like you weren't there for that long.
I was there for a couple months.
I was there for a week maybe.
And what kind of part were you playing, Emma?
Well, I was playing the bass in a band that was fronted by.
It was sort of a school of rock adjacent.
Would you say, Will.
Yeah, I would.
Kind of story.
Willie, what were you planned?
Oh, I played the lead singer of a hair band.
True story.
You got to check it out.
And Bradley was the guitarist and Fred was the bassist.
Yep.
But it was fun.
But yeah, I mean, you have not, I'm trying to think,
you just have not stopped working and doing awesome stuff
since the moment I became aware of you.
You've just been like consistently just doing cool thing after cool thing,
great film after great film.
It's pretty remarkable.
Not a lot of people.
And rare.
Basically, you haven't done anything as shitty as the rocker since the rocker
is what Will is saying.
I've done way worse movies
than the rocker since the rocker.
Oh my God.
Subjective.
Well, I think, maybe.
It is great.
It is good.
Let's not go too deep through the IMDB or whatever.
I met you once very briefly.
You were so kind years and years ago.
Blah, blah, blah, you never remember.
I think it was at SNL.
But I was like, oh, my God, that's Emma Stone.
And then, so when I did my research for today,
I didn't know that your name was Emma Lee.
I want to know these guys,
I know why it's called Emma,
but I want you to tell these guys
why you change it to Emma.
And then I also want to know about your dog bakery thing
that you worked at
because I have a friend who lives in Arizona
who is a company, it's a dog poop company.
She picks up poop, dog poop for,
you just call her and she picks up dog poop.
But it was in Scottsdale.
Oh, that's where I'm from.
I know.
That's amazing.
Well, my name was taken.
Have you noticed like there's been less dog poop around when you go home?
You know, now that you mention it.
You can't gauge how Sean's friends.
I mean, it used to be absolutely.
everywhere just piles that way.
But her gig, her gig is just, she's just a freelance.
She just goes around town.
Freelance poop.
And she's looking for just spare poop that's unclaimed and unbipped up.
You call it up if you don't want to pick up your dog poop.
It's called Poop Patrol.
Sherry's poop poop.
Who's compensating her?
The city?
Her clients.
People who don't want poop in their lawn, man.
Yeah.
Wait, I'm, I'm confused.
Wait.
So you call her just, so you just let your dogs kind of run free on your own lawn like all week.
And then Poop Patrol comes.
Oh, like a gardener.
You come up.
That's right.
A gardener comes over, picks up the poop.
Yeah.
Like instead of blowing the leaves and stuff,
there's a poop.
Wow.
I don't know.
30 jokes in there?
I didn't know where to.
Well, that's kind of why I brought it up.
It's such a funny job.
You take a tight five and gather them and then come back to us.
But wait, a dog bakery.
You worked at a dog bakery when you were a teenager?
Yeah, okay.
I worked a dog bakery when I moved to L.A.
when I was 15,
called Three Dog Bakery at the Farmers Market.
At the Grove?
I used to go there.
You worked there?
Yes.
Oh my God.
I mean, not for long, for like maybe six months.
Wow.
So, wait.
Johnny, this was pre-Ricky?
Yeah, this was years ago, years and years ago.
This was why I was 15, 20 years ago.
Yeah, that's when I had my two other dogs.
I used to go there to shop for them.
Do you think that we ever ran into each other then?
Probably.
Maybe.
Huh.
I think word would have gotten out that,
Will and Grace's Sean Hayes was there.
I think you're right.
I think I would have told everybody.
Guaranteed.
You probably should guarantee.
Oh my God.
Okay, so I must not have been working those hours.
We'll be right back.
All right.
Back to the show.
Tell these guys why you change your name from Emily to Emma.
Well, it was originally my name was taken at Screen Actress Guild.
Right.
When I got my card when I was 16.
So it was an Emily Stone.
Wow.
And so I originally changed it.
to Riley because what do you tell a 16 year old
that they can just change their name?
Right.
You pick a cool name.
And so I was like, I'll be Riley.
Right.
You could have changed it to Emma
middle name Lee.
Emma Lee Stone.
Right?
That you, that...
I don't know if I could pull off being a three-nameer.
Fuck, is there any way you could call her 20 years ago?
Could you call me 20 years ago really quick?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just one second.
We'll pause.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then we'll just...
That is a real thing, though, right?
That is a real thing, though,
all people who change their names
because of Sack,
because there's already somebody...
Yeah.
Michael J. Fox, I think,
was because there was already a Michael Fox, right?
One of the great ones is,
isn't...
I feel like Michael Keaton is Michael Douglas.
Oh, wow.
Oh, really?
And he changed his last name to Keaton
because Michael Douglas was Michael Douglas.
I just learned Albert Brooks's real name
is Albert Einstein.
I did not know that.
No.
swear to God.
That's unbelievable.
His brother was Bob Einstein,
you know, Super Dave Osborne.
That was Bob Einstein
and that's Albert's brother.
But anyway, Emily to Emma.
Emily to Emma.
Because...
Well, because you're trying to get to the spice girls' rap.
Yes.
You should change your name to Albert Einstein
because that was free.
That's true.
That one's free now.
Not being used anymore.
Wait, so you went to Emma.
I went to Emma because growing up,
I was an enormous...
I mean, still to this day I am,
but an enormous...
an enormous, sorry I'm slurring.
I've been up for four days.
You need to take a nap.
Yeah, I got to take a nap.
I was a huge Spice Girls fan.
And there was Emma, who was Baby Spice.
No way.
Crazy about her.
Yeah.
I love that.
When I was in, you know, like second or third grade,
I asked the teacher to call me Emma,
but it didn't ever stick.
But then I had the chance to do it permanently.
And here I am.
I love that.
Have you met the Spice Girls since?
I have.
Does she know that?
How is that?
girls now. I think she does
because she gave me a really special t-shirt
that she had signed. It was like from one
Emma to another kind of thing. It was pretty cool.
Did you keep it together or did you just totally
fan out of them? I did not keep it together at all, at all.
But I will say, the night before
I met them, we were going to their concert
in England when they
when they, you know, had done,
they did like a reunion tour a couple years ago
in 2019 and the night
before I went to a
party at somebody's
house and the
magician David Blaine was there.
Okay.
And he did a,
just an astounding trick.
You know, he did this card trick,
and then it was this whole thing.
It was an illusion, an illusion, if you want.
And it was like, and he pulled up his phone,
and the card was reflected in a picture on someone's,
you know, in the glasses of someone on a boat,
and it was this crazy thing.
And I got so excited,
now this is the tale's oldest time
because I'm about to tell you a story from yesterday as well.
Whoa.
I got so excited.
that I ran.
I was like,
I can't stand it
because I'm such a big fan of magic
and I couldn't stand it
and I ran
and I was wearing these
healed boots
and I slipped on the wood floor
this is the night before the Spice Girls concert
slipped,
my arm went back out behind me
and I broke my fucking shoulder.
When was this?
No blame responsible for that.
The summer of 2019
so the next day I'm supposed to go
to the Spice Girls concert
and I was like
there is no way on Earth
I'm missing this.
So we got in England one of these, you know,
things from boots, the drugstore,
this little sling.
And I hadn't even gotten an x-ray yet.
And I went and I was in so much pain
that actually meeting the spice girls
under those circumstances was probably better
so I couldn't do that in front of them instead.
And your excitement was so tempered by the pain you were in.
It was so tempered by the pain that I was like,
it's amazing to meet you guys.
Oh my God.
Like it was so brutal.
It was broken in two places.
And then yesterday,
I have bone density issues, that's clear, because I broke my toe yesterday.
No.
I did.
Are you kidding?
Doing what?
On what?
Getting out of the shower.
Yeah.
Well, you should have been lying down in the shower.
What do you mean getting out of?
I know.
You accidentally, you stubbed it on something?
I slammed it into something, and now it's completely black and blue and like all messed up.
It's all day.
And you're sick, and you showed up for us today.
God bless you.
Yeah, how did you not cancel?
It's a dream.
This is incredible.
Are you kidding?
I'm sitting on a computer with headphones.
This is lovely.
Half of one of those excuses would have made me cancel this thing.
God, I was just thinking, I would give.
I was so excited for this.
I would give anything for improved bone density.
Yeah.
Sorry, just sidebar.
Sidebar.
We need to take, what is it, Boniva or something.
Yeah, Boniva.
There's some pill to help our bone density.
But I've broken seven bones.
Before I was 30, I broke seven bones.
Emma.
Isn't that crazy?
Wow.
So then you seriously looked into this.
You seriously do have bone density issues?
There's an endocrinologist was like,
we got to talk about this.
Like something's up with you.
Right.
And did he come up with anything?
Just that I need to take a lot of vitamin D and calcium
and do apparently weight-bearing exercises,
like heavy lifting is what creates more bone density.
Well, you could just drink milk and eat like dumplings from chin-chin like Sean.
Jesus.
He has a glass of milk four times a day.
No, I have a glass of milk with dinner every night.
No, you don't.
I really do.
You're joking.
Why not? It's good for you.
That's Chris.
It's good for you.
It's vitamin Z.
Will you sit at dinner drinking a glass of milk?
Yeah, I saw it a week ago.
I just, I just stopped.
Are you just doing it to be adorable or you really enjoy it?
No, this is what he does.
No, I, I know why.
Like leaving a beaver.
You know why because.
He lives like he's in the 50s.
It's incredible.
12-year-old in the 50s.
Because water's too boring and soda has too much sugar.
so I just drink milk.
Well, you know, they have zero sugar soda now.
I'm not into it.
So, listen, I want to sit,
by the way, since we're on medical stuff.
I wish this was just a gallon of milk that I was sitting out.
That'll be so fascinating.
Wait, but is it true?
Because you have one of those cool, like,
million billion dollar voices, too.
Is it true that you, first of all,
didn't know you had asthma
until you had an asthma attack
while filming EZA, which I read?
And the other thing is,
did you really have a condition
when you were a baby
because you cried too much
and the major voice.
Is that true?
Yeah.
Because you were colicky
that gave you a raspy voice.
Like extremely colloquy
for five months.
What colic?
Can you imagine?
Now having a kid,
I cannot imagine
having a colicky baby
to that extent.
Five months.
What does that mean colloquy?
Collic is apparently
a condition
where your stomach
is killing you.
Like you're in a lot of pain.
It's like everything I can talk about
is just my medical.
No,
Oh, I know. It's fascinating.
But here's what I think it is.
It is the intestines or part of the GI track that is still developing and unkinking itself.
And there is a kink in the hose that is not, it still needs to grow to release itself.
And it takes a couple of weeks.
And the babies are miserable.
Miserable.
So it was like if I was awake, I was screaming myself hoarse every day.
And I think it was very, very traumatizing for my parents.
I see.
You know what's good for bone densities,
those, the astronauts,
you know that thing,
the power plate thing that vibrates,
that's supposed to be good for bone density.
Oh, thanks, well.
Isn't that kind of a 50s thing too?
Yeah.
A little belt around you that sheds?
I read it once over a glass of milk.
I was trying to.
I want to know, let's get to the career stuff
because it's really interesting to me.
Okay, great.
Wait, how old, no, hang on,
how old's your baby?
Let's just do it quick.
How old are you?
Two and a half.
Aw, sweet.
Boy, girl.
Girl.
Oh, sweet.
I didn't know that.
That's so fantastic.
Congratulations.
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
With your husband who you met at S&L?
Did you meet him in S&L?
Really?
Dave McCarrie?
Yeah.
And is he, what does he do with S&L?
He was a writer-director there for about five years.
Oh, nice.
Doing digital shorts.
And you met him there?
I met him there, yeah.
But we had a bunch of mutual friends, so, yeah.
So great.
I love that.
I feel like I was there that week, too.
Although you probably hosted a few times.
I remember, I remember being there once when you were hosting,
and I was just like,
Guys, wait, hold on.
I'm going to host on December 2nd.
I get to get my five-timers jacket.
No way.
I'm so excited.
I can't even stand it.
I'm like, I'm freaking out.
You're so good at it.
That's really, really cool.
Wait, so, Emma, you and Dave married in the pandemic,
and was that just because it was planned that way and you just kept it or you're like,
you know what, let's just do this now?
You were waiting for a pandemic, weren't you?
Didn't you guys say you wanted to get married, but let's wait for a pandemic to hit?
I read that somewhere.
I just trim the fat a little bit on the invite list.
Yeah.
You know, the week that I got married, I did open a refrigerator and the handle broke off and I got a black eye.
Oh, my God.
And that's where it stops.
You know, I do need a helmet.
I need a helmet and extensive therapy.
You got this new show with Nathan Fielder.
I want to skip ahead.
I know she's your guest.
Oh, yes.
But that looks really.
I know she's your guest, but I'll take this one.
It looks really fun.
First of all, he's great and not just because he's...
He's Canadian.
He's super funny.
You're super funny.
And when I first saw the ad for it, I was like,
these motherfuckers.
And then they got one of those safeties in there.
Yeah, they sure did.
Put a wig on him.
Took a boom out of his hand and said, go.
This is like a fucking,
this is like a fucking talent explosion.
Happening in one thing.
I'm so goddamn excited for this thing.
I'm so excited for this.
It's a wild ride.
Tell us about, how did that come to you,
to your orbit?
So Nathan and I have,
known each other through Dave and Dave's best friend Kyle Mooney have been...
I love, we love, Calhouni.
Huge love company.
And they've been best friends since they were nine years old.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, and so Nathan knew Dave and Kyle well, and I got to know Nathan for a couple years.
And then, I think in 2020, 2019, maybe, Nathan called me and said that he and Benny Safdi
had come up with this kind of loose idea for a show based on...
something that Nathan had really experienced,
where someone had said that they curse him in a moment.
And he was like, this probably isn't true,
but he found that it haunted him.
Sure.
And they started coming up with this sort of premise of what would happen
if you're kind of going about your life
and they had this idea for this couple who is trying to create
their own HGTV show.
But early on,
the husband, a little girl says,
I curse you.
And if that hangs over the premise of this whole show
and how that evolves and kind of makes them go crazy,
whether it's, you know, real or not.
And it just sort of spiraled out from there
and became this very intense show.
It's really, it is a comedy, but it's kind of not a comedy.
Kind of dark.
Yeah. Yeah.
It's very, yeah, there's a lot going on there.
So it was, no, it was a blast.
And we were in New Mexico for like half of last year shooting that.
And say the title again?
The curse.
Yeah, the curse.
I see posters for it everywhere.
And say the title one more time.
And just for the third time.
So, the curse.
I want to talk about poor things too, which is a movie that you have coming out.
The brilliant Yorgos Lanthamos?
I'm going to go see it this week.
You are?
Yeah.
Where are you going to see it?
I'm seeing it.
One of the screenings, because I'm going to be at those.
I'll see you there.
I just got a text for it, yeah.
Oh, great.
Was it me texting you to come to the screen?
Oh, he was you.
Do you go by Emma Stone?
Oh, shit, it is.
Yeah, interesting.
Yeah.
This is the second project with Yorgos?
Yes?
It was technically the third because we made a short film at the beginning of 2020.
and then so but it was it was yes it was the second following one so brilliant
amazing we made another one in the meantime we made another one in new orleans last year no really
with with willam with william yeah willans and poor things yeah yeah so we're done two together
and so for my sister tracy um yorgos did the favorite the lobster just a bunch of great
great kill a sacred deer incredible dog tooth which is yeah so poor things so so did you develop
it did you find it like
Did you just get an offer?
Like, how did that come to?
So, Jorgos and I did the favorite in 2017,
and right as we were wrapping up the favorite,
he told me about this book
that he and Tony McNamara,
who was the writer of the favorite,
had optioned,
and they were working on adapting.
And he just told me the premise of it,
and I was like, I beg of you,
I have to do this with you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so for the next few years,
we worked on things
and started kind of putting it all together
and he asked me to be a producer on it, which was amazing.
And so we kind of like assembled this team
and then at the end of 2021,
why do I keep saying all the dates?
Yeah, I don't know.
Because you're like Will, you have incredible recall on dates.
I do everything by date.
Really?
Month and year, yeah, yeah.
Me too. Everybody's birthdays?
Do you forget a birthday?
Can you forget a birthday once a birthday?
I can forget a birthday, but if you say like,
I can say like, oh yeah, like it was that time of year, that year.
It was this month.
March of 2023, he knows a difference between April of 21 and March of 24.
Maybe I function similarly.
Yeah.
But anyway.
Anyway, so we made it, we made it two years ago.
And yeah, it's just, it's, it's probably my favorite, my favorite thing I've ever gotten to do.
Really?
Yeah.
Wait, so with, you work all the time.
constantly, it seems like, which is great, and everybody can't get enough of you.
So when you go from set to set, other than your child, do you have like something, how do you set it up so it's home?
Or how do you set it up so it feels like, all right, I need to have at least this, this, this, and this in my trailer or this, this, and this with me?
What a fun question.
I'll tell you three things that always keep me company, no matter where I am.
Coke?
App.
Sorry?
Big plate of Coke.
She's got to get through it
I'm obsessed with the idea that I'm on Coke
just because I'm on cold medicine
Jason
Go with it
You know just suffering through this
On cold medicine
She's here on her on this
She's on a sick day
I have a broken
Broken foot
I'm near death
I know I can't believe it
No I apples and peanut butter
Really
Every day for a snack
I have apples and peanut butter
every day I have a Starbucks coffee.
Doesn't matter where I am.
Could be in the greatest coffee places in the world.
Europe, wherever.
Doesn't matter.
Find a Starbucks.
And what's your choice?
A coconut meisto.
Coconut.
No embarrassing to say.
What is it?
A coconut what?
Listen, they make you say meisto.
Which you know the Starbucks lingo
where they make you say these things.
It's a venty coffee.
Just a regular filter coffee.
It's a large.
Drip coffee.
A large.
With steamed coconut.
milk. Okay. And that's the misto part? That's the meisto. That's what makes it a misto.
So that's not a latte? It's not a latte. No, because it's not espresso. So you have apple,
by the way, I have peanut butter and rice cakes, always. Every day? Well, that's my treat. That's my
snack. That's your treat? Yeah, that's my snack. It felt like in a mid-after. Peanut butter and
rice cake? Oh, I love that. That's a healthy treat. It's not like you go and get all the
twizzlers from the crafty. Why do you guys go with just the apple or just the rice cake? Why do you need to spread all the
fatty nut butter
gives you a little hit of protein
and the big head of joy.
A lot of sugar.
I like the peanut butter with the apples.
It's delicious.
Sean, explain for, not for Tracy,
but for Jason, what joy is.
It's another kind of peanut butter.
Not for Tray.
Or no, that's Jiffy.
Emma, like
you were so fucking phenomenal
in the favorite, and you won for the favorite,
right?
No.
Yes, she did.
Nominated?
No.
She was fantastic, though.
Thank you so much.
nominated. Wait, but what was that...
You won a nomination is what I meant.
Did you really not win? I can't remember.
You did win. Not for the... Not for the favorite, no.
Which one did you win for?
La Lollah. Oh, that's right. Lala.
So I fucking love that movie, too.
God, you're so fucking good.
That's a truly embarrassing thing to have to sit here inside.
No.
Not for that one.
No, I want to know. I ask.
I want to know and try everything.
But wait, the favorite was you were still...
My mom says I'm always a winner.
Yeah.
And always her first.
favorite.
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
But was that, because when I've seen that movie,
when I watched that movie, I was like,
oh my God, this just looks like a colossal amount of work
that movie The Favorite.
Like, it just looks so grand and so massive.
That's just because a lot of it was in that fish eye lens.
That's what makes it look so grand.
All right.
You know what I mean?
That's a little trick of the trait.
That was in England, yes.
That was in England.
And La La La Land was here in Los Angeles.
It was in L.A.
Yes.
Favorite is such a good movie.
I just wanted to, apart from the work that, you know,
these guys were so tired.
But I, I, that movie was so good, Emma Stone.
Oh.
We'll be right back.
And now, back to the show.
Was that one of the hardest things we've ever done that?
What's the hardest one you've ever done?
Oh, God.
Physically, emotionally, both, whatever.
Lola had a bunch of stuff in it.
Oh, yeah.
You're going to learn.
The hardest thing I've ever done was on stage.
Yeah?
By far.
Sean loves stage stories.
I do.
You know I do.
Well, I've only done one professional stage show.
What went wrong?
Like 10 years ago.
Oh, you want a what went wrong story?
I want a bad theater story.
But here's the, I did cabaret.
And I only did it for three and a half months, which is so short by stage terms.
But enough.
I thought, I truly going into it, I was so beyond excited.
It was probably the greatest experience in my life for the same reason.
And I was like, oh, you just do it at night.
And then you do two shows a day on Wednesday, and you do two on Saturday.
And then you're a home.
Your entire life is eaten.
And it is so hard.
You have to live like a monk.
Like there's nothing, or at least I did because I lose my voice and I sing.
And it was like, I've never experienced something that physically taxing as an actor.
Yeah.
It was.
It was unreal.
I'm sure.
Because that was the hardest.
And when you, but did you anything go massively wrong?
Do you have any kind of night where you're just like, oh shit, my voice, nothing came out when I sang?
Oh, oh, yeah.
I mean, I had to take steroids multiple times.
No, yeah, no heart attacks in the house, thank God.
But that's, there are a lot of those stories.
But no, I, just to add to my, you know, things that are wrong with me, I'm extremely blind.
Blind, blind as a bat.
Okay.
And I wear
Contacts for that
And
They both popped out of my eyes
While I was singing maybe this time
And there's
And it cuts to
Really been reaching for a note
It cuts to it's really
Yeah I'm always reaching for those notes
I'm not a singer per se
And the
And the lights went dark
And you have to, you know, go off in the
In the blackout
And I couldn't see a thing
In the world
And I just went
and like slammed it.
It was terrible.
Getting off stage,
not being able to see it at all was.
That's terrifying.
And then couldn't find the contacts, right?
They were on the floor.
Couldn't find it.
But no, I always bring spares.
I have to travel with spares.
Yeah.
It's very important.
It would be great if you did the rest of the play
with glasses on, would have been great.
If you came back out with glasses.
Yeah, all of it gives me so much anxiety.
But when you...
I always had a fear, Sean, of getting hiccups on stage.
Yeah.
Oh my God, that's a great fear.
Have you had hiccups on stage?
No, but I had one thing where I had, like,
allergies.
and I could feel the post-nasal drip in the back.
And it was right before I had to sing,
what do you get when you fall in love?
You know, with Chris and John.
And I was literally like, what?
Oh, no.
Like forever.
Oh, God.
It was the worst.
Panic, tears, because I couldn't cough,
but I had to act like I was everything.
It's still, I have a million years.
Okay, I'm about to tell you guys something
that I think that you're not going to enjoy.
I know Jason's not going to enjoy this.
Oh, no.
What do you do when you get,
I'm going to ask you guys,
I'm going to go around to the panel here.
What do you guys do when you get the hiccups?
Do you have like a sure fire?
I don't have one.
I have a care.
Emma, I'm going to go first.
I have a cure, but people tell me that I'm wrong,
but not if you do it right, okay?
Here's the thing.
Yeah, you don't scream at people, do you?
This is the salt.
Put your arm up above your head.
Left arm.
Put it up above your head.
Well, just because I'm right-handed.
So if you're left-handed, you could do it.
Drivers, don't do this.
You take your, don't do it if you're driving.
Now, take water.
And you're going to, and I'm talking like tiny,
You go, swallow, swallow, swallow, swallow, swallow,
as you lower your arm slowly.
Well, nothing's going to happen because none of us.
You're not of us like idiots.
We're all doing it.
Well, we're just practicing.
Listeners, we're all doing it.
We're practicing.
I'm telling you, it is a hundred percent effective.
I feel incredible.
I feel amazing.
What do you guys do, Sean or Jay?
Nothing.
I wish I had something.
I take a deep breath.
Try this.
And I kind of let it feel it kind of go away.
and then I take water while I'm holding my breath.
It seems to work.
I've never told anybody this.
This is absolutely true,
and I can't believe I'm telling it.
We're ready.
Anytime I get the hiccups.
And I remember one time vividly,
years ago, our buddy Edgar Wright,
we did this thing called Don't,
which was like a fake movie trailer between,
there was a double bill,
like a Robert Rodriguez film or whatever,
and he made this fake trailer,
and I did the voice.
where anyway I remember going to record the trailer voice because I do don't even breathe
don't even blah blah blah I did this whole thing right it was in the West Village at this
recorded place and doing the thing and I'd had a soda I think and I got the hiccups because I was
taking in so much air and I was like what the fuck this is where I learned it and I was like
just give me a second I just got to because I'm like hiccuping on you know trying to record
and I go into the bathroom oh and I stick my finger down my throat and I make myself
gag and throw up a little bit.
Gone.
I get it.
And I came back out and I finished.
And that's what I do every time
when I get the hiccups now, I go, excuse me.
I get it.
That is disgusting.
Were you just gambling that that would work?
There's a better way, Will.
I don't know.
It works.
Do you fully throw up or do you just gag?
Ew!
Well, it depends on where I'm at.
You know what's going on.
You hate hiccups that you'll just make yourself puke?
I hate hiccups.
I will make myself on.
Were you just gambling that this would work?
Or is it something that you kind of read about?
I was just gambling.
I had no idea.
And I just did it.
Wow, that is.
Huh.
I did not know this.
You have a tattoo on your arm or your wrist or somewhere?
My wrist.
I want to see.
A very, very, very poorly done tattoo.
Look at this.
Now, this was supposed to be, I just want you to understand.
This was based off of a drawing that was drawn with a pencil.
Okay.
It looks like bird feet.
Does that look like a pencil?
Is it a cactus?
It looks like a pitch fork.
It's bird feet and it bleeds out more and more.
every single year.
I got it 13 years ago
and it just keeps spreading.
In 20 years, this is just going to be
what kind of half-ass tattoo artist?
Were you in a French prison or something?
I went into just kind of a random tattoo
place on 14th Street and I was just, yes.
Why didn't you consult with the sleeveless one?
He could have hooked you up with a great tattoo artist.
And now I've gone to good tattoo artist and said,
can I get this lasered off and read down?
And they were like, your skin is so thin there
that it's probably just going to look like you're burnt.
Like, it might be worse.
Oh, really?
So wait.
I don't know what to do with it.
And your mom got the same one?
My mom, my dad, my brother.
I mean, the story behind it is so special,
but it was like, and theirs all look great, by the way.
Really?
Because they all went to better tattoo people.
And I'm the one who's to cover it up for work every day.
And it's like raised up.
It's really.
Don't you hang out with Thoreau just a little bit?
Oh, I know Thoreau.
Yeah.
Okay, so he could have hook you up with somebody with maybe a better needle.
I didn't know him then.
Yeah, yeah.
This was 2010.
I love that your whole family has it, though.
Any thoughts on Justin?
This was October of 2010, Will.
You remember.
I love that.
By the way, I wasn't going to say it before, but, you know, when we shot the rocker, it was June of 2007.
Okay.
I know.
That's so crazy.
I know you know.
That is, yeah, Jason.
brought up a good point. Any thoughts on Thoreau?
And by the way, this is a safe, safe space.
Anything hurtful that you can think of?
Another segment we're introducing.
Well, you know, he suffers from eczema.
There we go. Does he really?
That's why he doesn't wear sleeves because he's proud
and he wants to show it. That's right. No, that's not
that's not true. Really? Where's his ex-Rizzo?
I don't know if he really does suffer from Excema.
It's just, you know, we've had a lot. We've had skincare conversations,
as I'm sure you can imagine, you know?
We once put on his Wikipedia page that he cries when he orgasms.
It's true.
Did someone take it off?
He did.
He did like an hour late.
I guess he got an alert or something.
Kimmel knows how to like break into someone's Wikipedia page.
The wrong person to know how to do it too.
I love that.
Will you guys put something on my Wikipedia page?
Don't put that one.
Put something different.
No, yeah.
We'll put Jimmy's brain.
We're going to put cries when Justin Thoreau orgasms.
Please.
Don't put that.
It would be funny.
It would be funny, though.
Can I ask about like early,
because you have a brother, right?
I have a younger brother.
You close with your brother?
Very, yeah.
Is he in the business?
This is the two of us.
No, no, he works at like a tech company.
And growing up, was he interested or no?
He was less like, you do that, I'm going to go over here.
Not at all.
He played football.
Yeah, where was home?
Where did you grow up?
Scottsdale, Arizona.
With the poop?
With the poop.
Remember?
Remember earlier?
the same conversation.
Huh?
How long have you been talking?
Remember from before?
It was like 25.
What did you say?
From earlier.
And good thoughts, good feelings about Arizona.
Do you miss it out there?
You still have family out there?
Yeah, I still have family out there.
The thing about Arizona is it's so hot.
It's so oppressively hot.
It's difficult to, you need to be built for that kind of heat.
And I'm not.
It's not a fun heat.
It's not a fun heat at all.
It's like 120 degrees daily.
And we're going to end, I want to, I wanted to ask you this because we're going to end on a industry business question.
I love a biz, a biz, a biz queue.
I love the biz.
I love the business.
I love the heat.
I love the buzz.
When you, you know, a lot of people who win an Oscar like you did for La La Land, they, you were amazing, so deserved.
I loved that movie.
I loved you in it.
Did you, a lot of people who win,
sometimes it's known as the curse of death with some actors.
First of all, I should ask, are you guys locked?
Before I give you these?
Are you picture locked on Lovelland?
Because you got the Oscar, great.
But a couple things.
Were it me?
I would try it a little harder.
I got some notes.
Yeah.
Good for you.
I was going to say, were you nervous?
Did you have anxiety?
You're like, oh my God, this is so great, I won the Oscar.
But did you feel like, I don't know,
a lot of times some actors who win Oscars,
you kind of don't see them for a long, like years and years and years.
Were you, did you have anxiety about like, crap, I won now people are sick of me?
Nope.
Nobody felt that way.
No.
No, but just like, who the fuck?
What kind of psycho?
Sean, why do you put that out there in the world?
They must hate me now.
Okay.
Sean, why did you tell us how you feel?
No, not.
won the Tony.
Is that what you were saying
when you were walking up your stage
to get the Tony?
Check.
Sean off my list.
I know how she feels about in a stone.
That came out wrong.
What I meant was like
did you have anxiety about like
I'm not going to work?
People are like people must think
like oh we you made it.
I left that this was a very
lucky situation because I had
I met Yorgos while we were
filming La La Land and I left the day
after the Oscars to go shoot
the favorite. Oh, that's great.
So it was kind of amazing
because the next day I went right back to work
and was back in... Did you have time to renegotiate
your deal on your way to location?
Yes, so that was...
I did delay my flight for a couple hours
just to call, just to call my lawyer,
but... By the way, that was
reopened just a salary portion. A couple new
deal points that I'd love to...
No, but by the way, that was a big compliment
is what I know. I'm completely fucking...
Okay, okay, okay. How many great, because you've been,
you've been not...
nominated, I'm sure, a million times for lots of great...
Lots of great awards for me.
Do you have a bunch of great unused acceptance speeches?
No, what?
No.
I bet you do.
But I bet you give some thoughts, some respectful time and some thought to what you would say up
there.
You're not one of these ingrates that would just, if I win, I win, I'll just go up there
and wing it.
I bet you've got some fun stuff that you said.
My dream is to have like a book, a coffee table book of people's unused acceptance speech.
That's a great idea.
That's a really good idea.
Maybe you should start compiling that.
You have to be anonymous though, wouldn't it?
Well.
Right?
The people with the speeches?
Yeah, because I guess it would be, but then how do you do an anonymous acceptance speech?
Everyone would know who it was, like the people they're thanking.
What were you going to say for the rocker?
Yeah.
If you had gotten up there for the rocker, well, who would you think first?
Probably just will.
Just will.
Thanks for being our guest today.
Thanks for having me.
No, but you got nominated for...
You got nominated for Lala and what you won.
You got nominated for the favorite.
And you got nominated for...
Silence.
The Birdman?
Is it the Birdman?
Yes.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And you had to work with Galvanakis.
Oh, God, I know.
What a fucking...
What a nightmare.
Is there a less talented guy in showbiz
than Zach Alphanakis.
You know, from your lips to God's ears.
I know.
I agree.
I couldn't agree more.
He was so, so sweet.
Anyway, yeah, no, he really is.
What are you going to do for us tonight,
and are you watching Golden Bachelor?
No.
What's Golden Bachelor?
I love that answer.
What is Golden Bachelor?
It's a Bachelor, but an older guy.
You should never know what it is, Emma Stone.
This is why you are you.
Because you don't know.
I'm just out here.
Breaking Bones, getting sick.
Not watching Golden Bachelor.
Well, now I'm going to look it up and watch it.
Sean went for a phase.
For a phase of his breaking bones, right?
Yep.
Early 20s, Chicago.
Hey, hey.
Oh, God.
Hey.
Emma, cool it, all right?
Okay, okay.
Sorry, sorry about that.
Sorry.
Emma Stone.
We're going to let you go.
We're going to let you heal.
We're going to let you get better.
We're going to make you feel better.
I'm going to send some soup over.
You don't need to send anything.
All right, good.
It'll be.
Okay, great.
I just saved myself a call to my assistant.
Thank you guys for having me.
I'm sorry I was such a, you know.
You're the best.
You're like incredibly fast hour.
Huge, huge, huge fan.
Huge fan.
You're the best.
Very, very sweet.
You're a, literally, you're a mega talent.
Yeah, mega.
Yeah.
True.
That's, you guys.
Emma.
Emma Stone.
Thank you guys so much.
Thanks for having me.
All the best.
Hey, Emma, one thing, I want you to remember one thing.
Yeah.
And I hope you've lived by this credo.
You can always say this to any guy.
If you want to be my lover, first you got to get with my friends.
Will?
If you want to be my lover.
That was truly beautiful.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I will take that with me.
Okay, got it.
You're welcome.
You not knowing that that was the spice girl's lyric is one of the more painful things.
Well, imagine what I think.
thought, because I didn't know it was a lyric, I just thought he was just saying that stupid
crazy sentence.
No.
Like what?
I was trying to connect with her.
Did you just call the spice girl's stupid and crazy for the lyrics?
Or not a lyric.
If it was just a goodbye sentence for a podcast interview.
And this is where I log off.
What about when James Cameron, when James Cameron won the Academy Award for Best Director
of Titanic, I had not seen the movie.
But when he walks up on stage, he says, I'm king of the world.
Did you say you've never seen Titanic?
At the time I had not seen it
When I saw him go up on stage and say, I'm king of the world
I thought, oh no, what did he just say?
I've never seen it, I know.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
I know.
You got a lot of homework to do.
Jason's listening to wannabe by the Spadice Girls.
Will you're watching Titanic and Sean, just get Ricky, you know.
Fix your cat.
Get him a little bit.
Emma, thank you for being here.
Thank you.
Bye, honey.
Feel better.
Thank you.
Bye.
Bye, bye, bye.
Good night.
Sean, you were right.
Great guest.
She did it while she was sick.
So nice for her dog.
Sick.
Sick as a dog.
This is worth, you know, when we do these late night records,
it's, you know, the stakes are high.
That it'd be a good guest and you nailed it there.
By the way, for the record, it was a 4 p.m. record.
So when you say late night, for most people,
they have a different.
Okay.
But the other thing is, I will say this.
And this is a compliment to you, J.B.
Not even a fucking, I'm not, there's no punchline.
She has a great work ethic.
Like a lot of people I know who started,
young in who were young in as actor as director whatever she has that same thing and you have
that same thing uh which is she's sick but blah blah i in all the years i've done stuff with you i've
never known you to call in sick not fucking once yeah oh there was uh plenty of times when i'd clear
my day when it was three three a m and i was uh still having fun yeah back sorry except for the one
except for when you blew your cola out when we were doing that fight scene on the rest of
development.
You did.
You fought too hard.
You broke my colon.
I know, that's true.
But anyway, she does have that great thing.
She's always just, God, she's so good.
You always, when you start listening off the stuff that she does and they're all so different,
you're like, yeah, yeah, I missed on her.
When an actor has never sucked, that's something.
She's in that category.
She's in that never sucked.
It's, I always say John Goodman, number one.
He's the first guy I always think of when I think never has never sucked.
And she's in that category.
There are few people who,
fall into that category.
And she's one of them.
Yeah, she's incredible.
I didn't get to ask her about,
I want to talk more about La Land about how it shot.
Get ready well.
Next time.
Next time, next time.
Honestly, nobody better.
There it comes.
Who's got it?
Yeah, well, I love Birdman, too, you know.
Oh, you know what I also like?
Do you ever see, bye, bye, birdie?
I couldn't even do it.
I couldn't even, I'm Chris, you're going to do that.
You're fired.
Sean.
Bye, bye, bye, birdie.
Wait, what, bye, wait a second.
You can't just start saying.
It's just, it's too.
You're too tight.
See, it's too late.
It's too late to even come up with a buy.
Well, I was going to say this.
I love that she got her name from the baby Spice
because she's such a fan of the Spice.
Spice, girl.
That's good.
That'll do.
Bye, everybody.
Smartless is 100% organic
and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico.
Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf.
Smart. Less.